it was love between you and Josh you
know over the off season there's a lot
of rumors a lot of trade rumors a lot of
chatter
um you know this was a different picture
than what we saw you know from the last
time that we played last season
um do you feel like there's any you know
misconceptions or or anything that
happened between you and Josh over at
all season yeah because I mean you go in
after 20 game
off a 20 Game season your last image of
me and Josh was uh the last after the
fourth down I'm saying they say a
picture is worth a thousand words so you
can garnish whatever you want from that
image and create a narrative behind it
and it'll fit I'm saying obviously
there's no football being played it's
just a lot of commentary and he says he
or she say so for me I feel like uh the
comments conception was was that I
wanted to leave but it was like
um I never said that you know I'm saying
I never came out my mouth and said I've
never had a conversation with anybody
that said it was just a tweet and it was
just like it's just a tweet that said
come and rescue me yeah yeah like I'm
like damn like I thought I thought we
all listened to Drake at one point you
know I'm saying of course like I like to
you know sometimes I do poke the bear I
hope to Bear people all the time but in
the same majority of the time is it's
Twitter or Instagram and I say listen
their social media you're saying you use
it how you want but we're all grown ass
people I'm saying like and as an adult I
feel like I'm on this on whatever I say
you know I'm saying but I feel like at
one point some people dive too deep into
things or take it however they want to
take it so for me I also say I'm not
responsible for how people react to
things I'm not responsible for it um how
somebody feels I'm more so responsible
on how I carry and I'm just happy to
have my quarterback yeah